I'm going
good time
I'm the wall
Oh
what's up wasteland Wanderers welcome
back to GameSpot's fallout mod of the
week where we showcase all the tools
you'll need stay comfy in the
Commonwealth this week could be seeing a
new home away from home and settling
into the new standalone version of vault
98 your very own underground vault to
build and customized your heart's desire
the vault can be found in the middle of
peaceful fair line Hill estates but
beware you may have to face some large
neighbors to keep you company there are
two separate parts of the vault the main
entrance that works like home plate and
allows you to decorate the welcome area
and the wider vault itself all stripped
out and bare ready for you to turn a
hole into a home the entrance section
can be equipped with vendors and
settlers as well as working with your
supply lines but gets a little cramped
when traders bring their brahmins into
the closed confine to the vault door to
make sure you really feel at home make
sure yourself and your visitors are
dressed appropriately the mod author has
added some vault 98 suits in a nearby
locker so you can look the part of
surviving vault dweller and as another
bonus you can build custom vault
generators and water sources so you can
keep the lights on and the plants
watered even in the cramped combines of
your new bedrock bedroom the mod Creator
is currently working on adding some law
and altering the decorations to the
vault as well as adding a unique vault
98 radio station custom items and even a
question for the vault likely all to
come after the fallout creation tools
have been released now is a great time
to pick up this mod especially if you're
planning on getting your grubby hands on
the wasteland workshop DLC coming soon
that way you'll have the wonderful new
suite of design options at your
fingertips to really give your voice
some character as well as letting you
make the most of the other settlement or
furniture mods you've got installed from
the Nexus I really enjoyed the
settlement building aspects of fallout
spending countless hours perfecting my
little homestead keeping it well stocked
and well defended so I love this mod it
combines all the aspects I love about
base building but gives players a new
environment to do so instead of the
dreary ruins of dilapidated buildings
this clean fresh vault will be my home
I'm really looking forward to seeing how
the author develops mod if you've used
it yourself then I'd love to hear what
you think about it so let your voice be
heard in the comment section below or
tweet your feelings at us using the
hashtag GS fallout and until next week
where we will be delivering some more
fallout goodness into your radiation
boxes stay safe out there waste lambda